من الآمن أن نقول إنه كان أسبوعا طويلا للغاية
بالنسبة لسعر أليكساندرا وجوشوا ، وهو أمر مرهق للغاية يوم
الاثنين الماضي ،
تقول ألكسندرا وجوشوا إنهما ذهبا للحصول على
لقاح الإنفلونزا مع أطفالهما الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين أربعة وخمسة أعوام
في وولغرينز في شارع سانت جوزيف
وتقول العائلة  لم تكن لقاح الإنفلونزا
ما حصلوا عليه على الإطلاق في الساعة 5 و 37 مساءً ،
اتصلت بي والغرينز لتقول إن
هناك
خلطًا بيننا لم نتلق لقاح
الإنفلونزا وأنا أحب جيدًا ما الذي حصلنا
عليه هو كما لو حصلت على حقنة كوبي 19
و  على الفور شعرت بما يعنيه هذا
بالنسبة لأولادي ، تقول العائلة إن
ابنها الصغير بدأ يصاب بالحمى
في الأيام التي تلت ذلك ، وقالت العائلة
إنهم أخذوا أطفالهم إلى طبيب القلب
وقالت إن
ابنتنا تعاني من ارتفاع في
ضغط الدم أكثر مما تريد  لمراقبة أن
لوكاس كان ابننا يعاني من عدم انتظام دقات القلب
وذلك عندما تسارع قلبك ، لكن
لم يكن الأطفال الذين يعانون من الأعراض فقط
يقول
ألكسندرا وجوشوا إنهم تلقوا بالفعل تطعيمًا كاملًا ضد مرض كوفيد باستخدام حقنة فايزر
، لذا حصلت للتو على شهادتي
البكالوريا  k في أبريل
وهذا ما كنت أحتاجه ،
لذا فأنا
قلق جدًا بشأن الأطفال ، أعني أنني
قلق كثيرًا بشأن الأطفال ،
لكنني أشعر بالتوتر مثل ما يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة
لنا أيضًا الآن لم تتم الموافقة على جرعة pfizer
بالنسبة للأعمار من 5 إلى 11 عامًا ولكن الأسبوع الماضي ،
قالت شركة فايزر إنها طلبت من
الحكومة الأمريكية الحصول على إذن استخدام طارئ
في تلك الفئات العمرية ،
لكن جرعة تلك الفئة العمرية أصغر
من جرعة البالغين الكاملة التي
يُسمح لـ walgreens بتقديم لقاح الإنفلونزا
للأطفال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 3 أعوام و  ما زال
يسعل رأسه بسبب السعر
الذي يدفعه للأسرة ، وهو يشتكي باستمرار من أن
جسده يؤذي معدته ،
وتؤذي صوفيا الآن الحمى.
يقول ألكسندرا إن لديهم موعدًا لمتابعة الطبيب
هذا الأسبوع لأطفالهم ،
أما بالنسبة إلى walgreens ، فنحن نريدهم أن يفعلوا ذلك.  لن
نحاسبك على ارتكاب خطأ واحد بل أربعة
أخطاء يمكن أن تعرض حياة أطفالنا
للخطر ونريد التأكد من
عدم حدوث ذلك مرة أخرى